on se demande jusqu'où ce président
bavard va détruire la fonction
présidentielle
quand il parle de vous en disons le
petit de gaulle un lapin duracell c'est
la fonction de président qu'ils
s'allient ou c'est vous qui les seuils
de salière diantre vous parler de
scandale
il faut ramener tout ça à sa juste
raison à plusieurs reprises il se plaint
du fait qu'il dise des choses aux
journalistes que ce square retranscrit
dans dans les journaux alors parfois
d'être manié dit de manière déformée
parfois il dit c'était of parfois il dit
je pensais quand même pas que ça allait
être écrit donc en fait ne peut pas
s'empêcher on voit maintenant quelle est
la personnalité de françois hollande un
homme qui n'aime que lui-même marie ce
livre c'est des entretiens et des
journalistes
avec je le crois l'objectif de faire en
quelque sorte aussi habile en tout ce
qui s'est passé en basirat solution qui
te prend part ce qui est vraiment une
faute et une trahison lourde à l'égard
du peuple français c'est de s'apercevoir
qu'en réalité ils savent et lui il sait
il sait les problèmes que pose
l'immigration
j'en appelle à la dignité à la pudeur
les divisions éloigne les français de
leurs dirigeants pour celui qui est
président de la république aujourd'hui
c'est françois hollande est je le
rappelle aux investigations on attend
mon appel du québec profession de dire
qu'il était persuadé que françois
hollande se représentera en 2012 un
nouveau 6 mais pensez vous au salon
c'est ce que dit nicolas mais ce que
vous ne le connaissons comme je le
connais il se représentera prix millions
de personnes ne savent plus où ils en
sont et que quand on leur dit la gauche
ils entendent hollandais gens n'ont pas
envie et quand on leur dit l'apra la
droite
ils ont vu les sept de look thouars ils
n'ont pas envie non plus entendu un
candidat nous expliquer qu'il allait
supprimer 500 me de fonctionner
dont 300 millions de jeunes c'est lourd
nouveau débat il n'y avait aucune grande
vision qui émergeait de ce débat non la
politique n'est pas une carrière au bout
de 30 35 40 ans on arrive aux plus
hautes fonctions
la politique est un engagement total
personnalités gravité et émotion les
maîtres mots de cette série un texte qui
évoque la résistance qui brandit la
force de l'amour contre celle des armes
je veux être utile christian estrosi
perd son procès contre le rappeur
infinite qui avait chanté je n'ai aucun
diplôme comme christian estrosi
je vous dis non cette entreprise
maléfique échoué à l'unité la liberté
l'humanité
au bout du compte prévaudront christian
estrosi n'a fait aucun procès à sarkozy
dj sarko qui pourtant l'avait qualifié
d'abrutis ayant une noisette dans la
tête
après les confessions de françois
hollande aux journalistes du monde
c'est au tour de ségolène royal
d'exprimer des doutes quant au projet
d'aéroport de notre dame des landes
face au blocage du site elle se pose une
nouvelle fois au premier ministre il
vaut mieux arrêter le pen la justice a
tranché
et donc quand il y a les propos comme
cela on ne revient pas sur la parole du
premier 3
je ne sais pas mais on ne revient pas et
on ne joue pas avec la démocratie parc
du projet se fera il s'ouvre aux arts
avec méthode et personne ne peut mettre
en doute
seulement l'autorité du premier ministre
mais l'autorité des électeurs parce est
un nouvel exemple lors je veux pas eu
des gros mots mais de ce qu'est devenu
ce gouvernement c'est à dire un
gigantesque foutoir vous imagine pas
comme ça finalement c'est c'est
surprenant nous entendre avec jean et
comme je n'ai jamais dit des gros mots
depuis qu'il est né comme qu'elle ferait
vraiment je suis ado comme les autres
comme vous ça vous arrive de jurer aussi
bon si ça m'arrive de jurer prix je
viens à florange dire que j'ai respecté
l'ensemble de mes engagements
la phrase du jour est signée françois
hollande le président de la république
donne ce matin une interview dans
plusieurs quotidiens locaux
j'ai toujours tenu bon il ne faut jamais
se laisse emporter par tel ou tel bout
de phrase sortie de son contexte
voilà ce que dit françois hollande prend
les hauts fourneaux ne tourne plus ne
fume plus n'existe plus là bas mais la
reconversion est en marche oui d'accord
mais bon si vous voulez je pense pas
qu'on puisse remplacer l'industrie
française
d'ailleurs florange étaient un site
rentable car c'est en toute discrétion
que françois hollande arrive sur le site
d'arcelormittal
il est attendu par la direction et
quelques salariés une visite sous
contrôle pour éviter toute image gênante
m
premier qui était tenue avant vous
voulez y avait 3000 300 cdi à 5 ans qui
se lever le matin qui ne travaillent sur
le site
aujourd'hui sont 2300 ça c'est factuel
est en cause c'est le dénigrement rituel
c'est le fatalisme c'est l'abandon
c'est la résignation qui souhaite
observer avec beaucoup de tension entre
les six personnes qui étaient autour de
moi
deuxièmement un déficit de politique et
un surcroît ou une surabondance de
gestion et d'administration par contre
je crois que dans cette ambiance
totalement glacée ou l'électro
encéphalogramme était totalement plat
c'est pour les commentateurs jean
frédéric poisson qui a gagné le débat on
se dit que justement quand un plat le
moindre friselis ressemble à un
tremblement de terre elle intéresse
plusieurs personnes qui me disent on va
voter jean frédéric poisson ça vous fait
quoi
c'est une d'abord c'est une très bonne
idée et je veux dire à tous les
manifestations que le 20 novembre le
poisson est à 2 euros
on en profite pour tirs de mortiers jets
de cocktails molotov
une épaisse fumée se propage près du
lycée hélène-boucher près dans ces
conditions là qu'il nous faut apporter
des réponses en termes d'abord
d'interpellation et de sanctions
extrêmement ferme que je souhaite
vraiment exemplaire des auteurs de ces
agressions parce que c'est insupportable
la proviseure tentera de ramener le
calme elle sera blessé au visage par
plusieurs jeunes et transporté à
l'hôpital
manuel valls prévient l'état poursuivra
sans relâche ceux qui s'en prennent à
nos professeurs nos écoles et aussi nos
forces de l'ordre fin de citation vous
dites carrément que sarkozy hollande ont
du sang sur les mains une accusation
très fort parce que c'est là que tous
ceux qui ont tous ceux qui ont organisé
cette fin organisé cette situation dans
laquelle nous sommes devenus des alliés
des semences et du djihad
le manque de moyens
il va régler le problème vous voyez tout
in voilà vous voyez comme c'est pas du
tout monsieur bourdin vous attendez-vous
d'habitude sympa mais là vous êtes
ignobles
c'est à dire il y aura des territoires
qui seront concédées à l'islam où il y
aura des tribunaux islamiques comme dans
certaines régions d'angleterre où on
pourra pratiquer légalement la charia ça
s'appelle une méthode très particulière
du journal c'est la question accusations
est ce que c'est vrai que vos assistance
met à poil
vous venez de refuser de vous asseoir
vous sur le canapé de karine marchand
sur m6 alors que la plupart sont allés
dire papa maman ma première masturbation
c'était la gt1 qu'est ce que vous a
proposé à vous c'est dans quelques mois
là c'est quand même c'est vrai mais bien
sûr mais savez je suis aussi comme vous
l'actualité je vois que parfois la forme
proposition s'adonne décathlonien
compréhensifs
voilà ce que dit holland mélenchon il
fait partie des soldats perdus il se
sent humiliée je connais depuis si
longtemps
je les ai vus ramper pour entrer au
gouvernement jospin voulait c'est bien
lui qui lui venimeux comme comme pas un
vrai drame
aujourd'hui c'est ça il n'a un prime
plus vis-à-vis des français il est
déconnecté des français quand vous voyez
alain juppé
vous dites quoi la population qui
vieillit j 1 de plus en plus vieux oui
oui c'est pas faux mais mais mais
revenons à vos engagements politiques
est ce que vous sentez un peu
aujourd'hui comme un missionnaire c'est
une position que j'ai bien connu je me
souviens du premier ministre de l'époque
disant je suis à la tête d'un etat en
faillite et qui cinq ans plus tard les
600 milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire à la france par siffler
et huer à la sortie du directeur général
de la police nationale
hier jean marc falcone était pourtant
venu à evry pour appeler à l'apaisement
ils ont dit maintenant dit jean-marc
falcone démissionnant il y a hier n'a
entendu monsieur ministre cieux
laissez-moi aller au bout de mon réseau
primé on l'a entendu non à l'évidence il
n'a pas été entendu
un fonctionnaire s'est même jeté sous
ses roues pour le forcer à descendre de
son véhicule
aujourd'hui chacun se croit tout permis
il est vraiment grand temps de rétablir
l'autorité de l'état
certes la loi doit être respectée et
bien sûr par tout le monde mais leur
exaspération aujourd'hui atteint un
degré tel que les pouvoirs publics
doivent réagir
les policiers repartent aujourd'hui ont
peur ils ont peur parce que ils sont pas
en sécurité parce que ceux qui les
agressent ne sont pas suffisamment puni
par la justice
marc le front national aujourd'hui
intervient quasiment survient même si
nous avons vu sa patte
houssam ferait pas de pattes du front
national il ya un vif soutien ça c'est
évident un soutien sans faille du fond
national prix n'ont plus d'arguments et
la seule chose qu'ils trouvent dans
leurs vieux placard à balais c'est la
mise en cause du front national oui tant
mieux si c'est vrai que les policiers
sont avec nous on n'est pas obligé de
politiser tous ces problèmes on peut
regarder les problèmes en face ça c'est
le rôle des responsables publics d'un
homme d'état rien le conseil municipal
dirigé par robert ménard a été quelque
peu perturbée des réfugiés doivent en
effet être hébergés dans les centres
d'accueil à béziers ce que refuse robert
ménard privateer il a été lu en étant
soutenu par le front national voilà il
est amer indépendant voire des ratios
d'endettement soi-disant fallacieux une
épargne nette négative et surtout un
emprunt qualifiés de fictifs
voilà ce qui fait dire à l'élu
socialiste matthieu rouveyre que le
maire de bordeaux dissimule une
situation financière explosive
manipulation politique il n'ya pas
évidemment de déficit caché et je le
répète la lettre que le préfet leur
envoyais est totalement explicite sur ce
plan là donc je suis très serein car
nous menons nos investigations pendant
des mois paie en l'occurrence la règle
en un an
828 euros estrosi ne vous permet pas de
dire avec beaucoup de médiocrité on vous
respecte par la surprise politique du
jour cécile duflot éliminé au premier
tour de la primaire écologiste tout le
monde voulait qu'on sorte du
gouvernement mais comme c'est cécile il
annoncé la première on lui fait payer le
fait qu'elle ait eu raison avant les
autres qui lui ont fait payer que europe
écologie c'était elle et c'est la
catastrophe politique donc qui l'ont
éjecté éliminé dès le premier tour
la favorite exprimé sa déception sur
facebook une défaite à mon avis très
difficile parce qu'effectivement elle
six voiliers au niveau de la
présidentielle et la manière de loin oui
bien sûr c'est d'ailleurs je pense aussi
cela qui est paye le côté coupeur de
têtes des dévers qui continuent un peu à
une forme de suicide collectif free jean
vincent placé
à chaque fois qu'il fait une déclaration
se demande qu'elle pourrait peut être
l'argument juste avant qu'il fasse sa
déclaration qui aurait pu faire qu'ils
disent exactement le contraire elle est
partie en dix ans en ne pensant pas aux
conséquences que ça aurait pour
l'écologie résultat elle a abîmé
l'écologie et sa stratégie elle s'est
retournée contre elle par une morale le
cynisme en politique de madame duflot
quête ministre qu'après à cracher dans
la soupe qui n'émet que par son intérêt
personnel a été balayée par les
militants écologistes
j'ai entendu hier le ministre de
l'intérieur va ce qui nous sert de
ministre de l'intérieur qui a osé dire
honte sur lui qu après 4h30 au pouvoir
c'est moi qui étais responsable des
manifestations de policiers
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour dire aux
candidats à l'élection présentielle
nicolas sarkozy que la manière dont il
s'est exprimé sur les ondes ce matin
ne correspond pas à ce que ce qu'est ma
conception de la politique et moi la
façon dont elle est ministre de
l'intérieur ne correspond pas à l'idée
que je me fais d'un ministre de
l'intérieur qui devrait devancer hommes
et qui doit les défendre mais 157
déplacement depuis 2013 mais c'est plus
bruno le renouveau cetc forrest gump ou
recettes dites moi en plus bien sûr de
vous permettez je me cieux le maire je
me permettrai pas de vous appeler par
votre prénom
non monsieur vous m'appelez mallem joie
chez arnaud mais vous ne m'appelez pas
ghislaine je suis pas votre ami
ce troisième et dernier débat
présidentiel constituait l'ultime chance
pour donald trump de combler son retard
sur hillary clinton dans les sondages à
leur arrivée les deux candidats ne se
serre pas la main spect élections